ああああああ
こんにちははじめ社長です皆様
世の中のものと思うの何でかついてるかわかりますか
そう全てあのある混じってるんです
[拍手]
嘘ですそしてみてください子供オシャレな服だが悪さんって書いてあるんです
こんなてちゃって見たことないですよハイジャックで皆さん僕も youtube の
動画とるべくもたまに使うんですけどもねぇ外さ
接着力や
やばくないですか結構いろんな趣味のアロワナかあると思うんですけどこれ何がすごい
かっていうと瞬間接着剤なんですよ
でプラスチックにも使えるし国にお付き合いし金属木材統計
もういろんなものをくっつけることによく使われるんですけども実際にどれくらいもの
にくっつくのかっていうのはちょっと口で言っても伝わりづらいところがあると思うの
で今回はこのあなたを作ってここ
皆さんにあろうルファの強さを伝えればいいなと思っております
では早速ものをくっつけていきましょう
俺のサインだけどね僕も一般つくんだけどとりあえず何でもつくように何度も作っ
[音楽]
ポップポップいきましょう付け歯
中古で見るだけでいいんですねつけすぎるとよくないからちょっとうすーく
どうでしょつけます俺の机さん
なーやばい終わった終わったです繰り返し見てきたん
ねぇ
ついたとか100万ってレベルチャーコップです
コップてないんだねくっつくなもんねー
[音楽]
続いてはたちのパソコンです家のパソコンどげんすごくが買ってあげたんでー
つけてもいいと思います雑費てるね私の買ってあげてもいいねっ
つけていきますただここだろうねポイント
うすーくつけます
[音楽]
太平
入ってますね
a
終わった終わりましたえっ
持ってに m 進むああーー
動かしたいん
第一こんな例えばパソコン持ってときてーったら
って結構たば思い出これくっついたらすごいと思います
[音楽]
ん
スイカ出るととあの bbr じゃんお客さん一人にはですね
このスキームでつけたらコレ
ピン子にします
ていますバッハ
[音楽]
少ない病です持つブルーています
パグちゃんとはがしておきますのでは
山朝から本当にっ
[音楽]
まぜっちょっと
東洋兵が鳴りと来てもらっていいですかはいそれじゃ
ある日ちょっとた立下で待っててー
そうだしますはい
値段 by されません
つけない越前握手会って会えばです
あっうん
ええええええええ愛顧0
そういうことがそういうことねぇ
うーんもうわかりましたもうにが生んだら誰ですよね
ショーツ接着接着ないですよね何ですかこれね
[音楽]
ロシェ
ああ
あーちょっとこっち来てもらっています
パソコン物を
てあるん
だってっ
えっ
いやこれダメだろうやっちゃう
これもセグでこれやっちゃう皆やつ
じゃあ全部取りちょっとじゃんねー
は
うわぁああ t まあいい始められます
[音楽]
うんん
me
タイマーねー
ani came
ています
いた
g 10ワンピースもちろんあのからさー
第プレイさあ持ち味から揉んでるん
ん
沢山の
て言ってくださいん
既存のケースの盗難でもっ
おお確か rwj
新しいのなどは別にいいんじゃない
新しい
まあ新しくしよう高
ですねそれぞれ1ん
[音楽]
おっ
俺の携帯はん
ああああああ
嘘じゃねえええネーナに会っ
ですかーっで薄めは入りともうちょいうちからがあるというアレだけど
えっ
[音楽]
car
すげークロレラ異母兄ず
座れるある人気です
はいというわけでパターンワールファンの強さここ分かりいただけましたでしょうか
つけれるものには限度があるんですけどもめちゃくちゃ強力なんで大変のものが作れる
かなと思っておりますって言わですねあろう arufa さんで超獣研究
キャンペーンを実施しております
某夏だもんでで超獣元凶なんですけどもツイッターで超自由研究家
画像つぶやくだけで豪華な賞品がもらえるかもしれません
大保なんですけどもアロンアルファの公式 twitter をフォローで走った上で
自由なあのアナウンサーをつけて
写真を投稿するだけで応募完了になっております長寿いう謙虚な画像ってことはなんか
こう
それっ膜みたいなやつをつけるやつとかひょっとしたらいいか
知れませんでコレとかねぇ
そしてプレーンでの中にはこちらの
んめっちゃ pop やな始めさせをかけるアロンアルファーのスマホ k 様れます
ので良かったらみなさん是非投稿して応募してみてください
詳しくは動画概要欄に書いてありますのでみなさんぜひチェックしてみてください
他にもたくさんかくあるねそういうわけで私もアラームを使った
さらなる何か面白い録画できない課金厨してみようと思うよ
じゃあな
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ